[Music]
what the [ __ ] is
[ __ ]
what the [ __ ] are they doing
you want to see some fireworks
all mate
not everyone is ready
[Applause]
yeah you better back up a little bit
more man
[Music]
no fear
that's right
[Music]
oh it's good
i hate pewdiepie because pewdiepie sucks
and his hand
sucks fanboy sucks pewdiepie sucks i
hate [ __ ] pewdiepie don't call me fat
because you fat too [ __ ]
there we go
brush i'll have you know i love you
i'll never forget you
[Music]
this is it
hey i'm actually fine
i'm gonna use my last name
this one's for timmy
this is it for private pitch
sorry i don't think i'm gonna make it
i'm alabama tell my subs
tell the brows
did it for that
private pie i got good news
you've taken out the enemy they're all
dead
really
ah
well how about that [ __ ]
i think pewdiepie probably does prank
videos like with dick slaps i don't know
surprise [ __ ] sample surprise
[ __ ]
surprise [ __ ] oh my god no no
man
oh what the [ __ ] was the zero deaths
periods never dies
[Music]
oh
haters doubted that i couldn't do it
but they were
this is art like this is art
you can't argue with art
hey
[Music]
[Applause]
oh
i will find you
um hi
i will look for you
and i will fist you
bro fist
you
are you crazy
no
i'm pewdiepie
um
okay
i'm really feeling this
i'm in another game
oh my god
there's a car level coming up
how you ladies doing more
more
yeah
ah
tastes good
yeah
more more power
[Applause]
it's tricky part are you nervous about
playing with me uh you know i think you
should be nervous yeah i've seen you
play conant you're pretty awful
we can't make any more mistakes
cut
all right you said there's a red wire
no
what does it say
it's the one million one and it's
[ __ ] broken congrats for surpassing
one million oh that's cool that happened
years ago give me 44 of these hey jack
this is what your fans think you look
like but this is what you really look
like
which is convenient because your videos
are about as cringy as a dub commercial
i can't [ __ ] send you your son of a
[ __ ] i think this guy is actually legit
you're [ __ ] useless you don't worry a
little god oh oh hey
no thousands of dollars
if you shave
i'll make it so that marzia
won't
make me lose
they call me beastmaster64
i'm the greatest pokemon hunter alive
[Music]
step-by-step
oh my god
if pokemon aren't real
then dogs aren't real either
[Music]
i can't believe this happened
i can't believe this you won't believe
this she doesn't believe me i can't
believe
these kids can you believe this i can't
believe this i can't believe i felt i
can't believe it i can't believe i found
this
i can't believe it can you believe this
i can't believe it
he can't believe it
get the boat we believe you
get the vote get the polka [ __ ]
i'm gonna have to send the poker [ __ ]
oh come on poker [ __ ]
go poke
ah come on
oh
shut up
what the [ __ ] are you doing yeah what
the [ __ ] am i doing what the [ __ ] are
you doing god damn it what the [ __ ] am i
doing what the [ __ ] am i doing what the
[ __ ] are you doing i'm not a vegan
i wasn't dead oh my god
[Music]
because you had a
you sing a sad song just to turn it
around if you don't have a core message
that's making a positive impact on the
planet
oh my god there it is
remember me
cameraman
the sky news posted popular youtuber
pewdiepie unverified due to suspected
relations with isis seems legit right we
got it
[Music]
where's the drum seriously okay
[Applause]
most important part the most important
part here comes okay pewdiepie is gay
[Music]
you can even scoop your tongue like that
and you hold it and then you just
[Music]
him mid mine on dna fire the canon
send in the helicopter
[Music]
my face is just like oh god this is
going to be on the internet forever now
[Music]
to get your core message across you
really gotta hit those points
fast marina get it fast as much
information as [ __ ] possible go you
should watch cowspiracy because it's a
very good thing to watch but it's very
gory so i don't recommend watching it
what the [ __ ] does that mean oh [ __ ] i'm
renata bliss i'm menasha please i'm
renata bliss your menager please renata
bliss manager please
please satan
no no more dances
[Music]
oh no you saw me
oh
oh you saw me that's embarrassing
if you sold everything what do you have
now
[Music]
i have bullet balls
i don't even have a home to go back to
even have a home to go back to we're
staying in my car
[Music]
come from all four this is i don't
understand you don't understand i'm
gonna pleasure myself with this fish it
is pleasure yourself what the [ __ ]
[ __ ] this what the [ __ ] me you
recommended the thing you reckon
[Music]
no
can you like lock him in and then just
we leave him in there
[Laughter]
dude nine hours later no holy [ __ ]
charlie you just locked it
oh wow what is it what do you think
cause you have green hair you're better
than me i didn't turn off the comments
you want me to take it off not now we're
filming
[Laughter]
keep your eyes open and look at me when
you kiss me
[Music]
doesn't work if you don't get 50k likes
so i mean you don't need to hit it or
anything but it's [ __ ] hitting hey yo
what is up 50 million likes can we hit
it on this video 50 million smash that
like button it's right down there i know
you've seen it what are you playing
don't eat anymore you're crazy i put a
whole pipette of this crazy stuff in it
but you actually didn't yeah
michael for real yeah
you know part of me is angry
but the other part is real proud
that you try to kill me i'm poppy i
swear to you i had 50 million subs when
we hit 50 million i am deleting my
channel
i want to die
i can't find it
i think she's
she's looking for her quality content
technically now at 1.3 million
next ingredient every christmas was a
sad memory because grandma was alcoholic
but we have to honor her recipe
one million dislikes or i'll drown
myself
[Music]
that was the joke
that was it that was the
first of all
we did this
oh it's got the brofist it's a custom
that's really [ __ ] cool an exclusive
ultra rare it smells it smells lovely
alright i hope you enjoyed this montage
and if you did make sure you leave us
actually why don't you check out another
montage that we did last year i think
2016 was one of my favorite years on
youtube so far and it wouldn't have been
possible without you guys watching
subscribing belling and all that [ __ ] so
i appreciate that and thank you it means
the world to me
before you click
bro fist
you